and I was just briefed on it and to  disgrace what's happened with respect to  the things that were done to our country  it should never again happen to another  president it is incredible  far worse than I would have ever thought  possible and it's it's an embarrassment  to our country it's dishonest it's it's  everything that a lot of people thought  it would be except far worse so I'm  going to get some very detailed briefing  but briefings but they they are it's a  very sad it's a very sad day when I see  that or sad day when a lot of people see  that they have no nothing it was  concocted and you say would you want  that was a probably something that's  never happened in the history of our  country